when i was a kid
i experienced something so powerful i
spent the rest of my life
searching for it but in all the wrong
places
what i experienced wasn't virtual
reality
it was music and this is where the story
begins that's me
listening to the beatles white album and
the look on my face
is a feeling that i've been searching
for
ever since music goes straight to the
emotional vein
into your bloodstream and right into
your heart
it deepens every experience
fellas
this is the amazing mackenzie stubborn
and joshua roman
music yeah
music makes everything have more
emotional resonance
let's see how it does for this talk the
right piece of music
at the right time fuses with us on a
cellular level
when i hear that one song
from that one summer with that one girl
i'm instantly transported back there
again
it's stacy here's the part of the story
though
where i got a little greedy i thought if
i added more
layers on top of the music i could make
the feelings
even more powerful so i got into
directing music videos
this is what they look like
that's my brother jeff sorry about this
jeff
here's me just so we're even
incredible moves should have been a
dancer
these experiments grew and in time
started to look
more like this
and both i'm searching for the same
thing though to capture
that lightning in a bottle except i'm
not adding moving pictures over the
music
added narrative dimension yes but never
quite equated
the power that just raw music had for me
on its own
this is not a great thing to realize
when you've devoted your life and
professional career to becoming a music
video director
i kept asking myself do i take the wrong
path
so i started thinking if i could involve
you the audience more
i might be able to make you feel
something more as well
so aaron coblin and i began auditioning
new technologies
that could put more of you inside of the
work
like your childhood home in the
wilderness downtown
your hand-drawn portraits in the johnny
cash project
and your interactive dreams in three
dreams of black
we are pushing beyond the screen trying
to connect more deeply
to people's hearts and imaginations
but it wasn't quite enough it still
didn't have the raw experiential power
of pure music for me
so i started chasing a new technology
that i only had read about in science
fiction
and after years of searching i found a
prototype
it was a project from nonidella pena in
mark bullets lab in usc
and when i tried it i knew i found it
i could taste the lightning it was
called virtual reality
this was it five years ago when i ran
into it
this is what it looks like now
and i quickly started building things in
this new medium
and through the process we realized
something that vr
is going to play an incredibly important
role in the history
of mediums in fact it's going to be the
last one
i mean this because it's the first
medium that actually makes the jump
from our internalization of an author's
expression
of an experience to our experiencing it
firsthand you look confused i'll explain
don't worry
if we go back to the origins of mediums
by all best guesses it starts to run a
fire
with a good story our clan leader is
telling us about how
he hunted the woolly mammoth on the
tundra that day
we hear his words and translate them
into our own internal truths
same thing happens when we look at the
cave paintings version of the story
the book about the mammoth hunt the play
the radio broadcast the television show
or the movie all of these mediums
require what we call suspension of
disbelief
because there's a translation gap
between the reality of the story
and our consciousness interpreting the
story
into our reality i'm using the word
consciousness
as a feeling of reality that we get from
our senses
experiencing the world around us
virtual reality bridges that gap
now you are on the tundra hunting with
the clan leader
or you are the clan leader or maybe
you're even
the bully mms
so here's what's special about vr in all
other mediums
your consciousness interprets the medium
in vr
your consciousness is the medium
so the potential for vr is enormous but
where are we now
what is the current state of the art
well you're here
we are the equivalent of year one of
cinema
this is the lumiere brothers film that
allegedly sent a theater
full of people running for their lives
if they thought a train was coming
toward them
similar to this early stage of the
medium of this medium
in vr we also have to move past the
spectacle
and into the storytelling it took this
medium
decades to figure out its preferred
language of storytelling in the form of
a feature film
in vr today we're more learning grammar
than writing language we've made 15
films
in the last year at our vr company verse
and we've learned a few things
we found that we have a unique direct
path into your senses
your emotions even your body
so let me show you some things and for
the purpose of this demo we're going to
take every direction that you could
possibly look
and stretch it into this giant rectangle
okay here we go
so first camera movement is tricky
in vr done wrong it can actually make
you sick
we found if you move the camera in a
constant speed in a straight line
you can actually get away with it though
so the first day in film school
they told me that you have to learn
every single rule before you can break
one we have not
learned every single role we barely
learned many at all but we're already
trying to break them to see what kind of
creative things we can accomplish
in this shot here we're moving up off
the ground i added acceleration
and i did that because i wanted to give
you a physical sensation of moving up
off the ground
and in vr i can give that to you
so not surprisingly music matters a lot
in this medium
as well it guides us how to feel
in this project we made with the new
york times zach richter
and our friend j.r we take you up in a
helicopter
and even though you're flying 2000 feet
above manhattan
you don't feel afraid you feel
triumphant
for jr's character the music guides you
there
contrary to popular belief there is
composition
in virtual reality but it's completely
different than film where you have a
rectangular frame
composition is now where your
consciousness exists and how the world
moves around you in this film waves of
grace which was a collaboration
between verse the united nations gaba
aurora and emerald ismail
we also see the changing role of the
close-up in virtual reality
a close-up in vr means you're actually
close up to someone
it brings that character inside of your
personal space a space that we usually
reserve for the people that we love and
you feel an emotional closeness to the
character because of what you feel to be
a physical closeness
directing vr is not like directing for
the rectangle
it's more of a choreography of the
viewer's attention
one tool we can use to guide your
attention is called spatialized sound so
i can put a sound
anywhere in front of you to left to
right even behind you and when you turn
your head
the sound will rotate accordingly so i
can use that
to direct your attention where i want
you to see
next time you hear someone singing over
your shoulder it might be bono
vr makes us feel like we are part of
something
for most of human history we lived in
small family units
we started in caves and moved to clans
and tribes and villages and towns and
now
we're all global citizens but i believe
that we are still hardwired to care
the most about the things that are local
to us
and vr makes anywhere and anyone
feel local that's why it works as an
empathy machine
our film clouds over seizure takes you
to a syrian refugee camp
and instead of watching a story about
people
over there it's now a story about us
here where do we go from here
the tricky thing is that all previous
mediums the format
is fixed at its birth film has been a
sequence of rectangles from muybridge
and his horses to now the format has
never changed
but vr as a format as a medium
isn't complete yet it's not using
physical celluloid or paper
or tv signals it actually employs what
we use
to make sense of the world we're using
your senses
as the paints on the canvas but only two
right now
eventually we can simply have all of our
human senses
employed and we'll have agency to live
the story
in any path we choose and we call it
virtual reality right now
but what happens when we move past
simulated realities
what do we call it then what if instead
of verbally telling you about a dream
i could let you live inside that dream
what if instead of just experiencing
visiting some reality on earth
you could serve gravitational waves on
the edge
of a black hole or create galaxies from
scratch
or communicate with each other not using
words
but using our raw thoughts
that's not a virtual reality anymore and
honestly i don't know
what that's called but i hope you see
where we're going but here i am
intellectualizing a medium i'm saying is
experiential
so let's experience it in your hands you
hopefully hold a
piece of cardboard and let's open the
flap
and tap on the power button to unlock
the phone
and for the people watching at home we
are going to put up a card right now to
show you
how to download this experience on your
phone yourself and even get a google
cardboard
of your own to try it with we played in
cardboard boxes as kids
and as adults i'm hoping we can all find
a little bit of that lightning
by sticking our head in one again
so you're about to participate in the
largest collective
vr viewing in history
and in that classic old-timey style of
yesteryear we're all gonna watch
something at the exact same time
together
let's hope it works what's the countdown
look like i can't see
five four three
so
let me tell you how i shot the cover of
the new york time magazine
walking new york
and i had to be perfectly vertical so i
could grab it
and when i was perfectly above you know
with the wind we had to
do it a few times then i keep shooting
dear lord protect us from evil
for you are the lord the light
you who gave us life took it away
let your will be done please bring peace
to the many who have lost loved ones
help us to live again
than others right now
sometimes i think we are the ones in
charge
how was it
that was the cheap way of getting you to
do a standing ovation i just made you
all stand i knew you applaud at the end
of it
i believe that everyone on earth needs
to experience
what you just experienced that way we
can collectively start to shape this
not as a tech platform but as a humanity
platform
and to that end in november of last year
the new york times and verse made a vr
project called the displaced
it launched with one million google
cardboard sent out to every sunday
subscriber
with their newspaper but a funny thing
happened that sunday morning
a lot of people got them they were not
the intended recipients
on the mailing label and we started
seeing this
all over instagram
look familiar
music led me on a path of searching for
what seemed like the unattainable
for a very long time now millions of
kids
just had the same form of experience in
their childhood
that i had in mind
only i think this one surpasses it
let's see where this
leads them thank you
you